we talk a lot about these pickup artists
obviously i know that's that's something
that we've been going down the rabbit
hole lately
i found one that's a little different
than the other ones i found a black
pickup artist
okay i want to introduce you i mean
that's just a regular black guy right
oh yes i want to introduce you to
anthony this is real last name
i want to introduce you to anthony spade
let's give it a second just give it a
second
so it feels good so it feels good it
feels like like what i could only
describe
as like odjada like when you get like
the feels like when
you know when you get like the bubbles
in your chest when you go and like
that's what it feels like like bad gas
whenever you do something like this
okay it's passed we good
yeah i feel good you feel good okay
knock it off
spade
um he's a pickup artist so this title of
this video is why sigma males are more
attractive than alpha males now
you're looking at this guy so before we
even hit play because you're pretty good
at this stuff
uh what do you think his voice sounds
like i've heard it so i can't tell you
to be cheating
um it's probably gonna be a little bit
higher pitched not like not like
falsetto but he's gonna be a little
almost like a drake
okay ready why sigma mills
are more attractive than alphago stay
tuned
welcome to the anthony spey channel all
right but why does anthony spage channel
look like the nfl whenever they're
switching over to does it not there's
too many moving parts there's too many
this is literally all right let's go to
tail of the tape
all right he's completed four four
touchdowns today
his qb pass rating is 12. you know you'd
write i agree with you but i wouldn't
i wouldn't i'll say nfl it looks like
something the xfl would do
or battlebots yes it's not that high
grade
right yeah get ready for your daily red
pill you ready
i hate i hate this stinger i hate this
makes me angry
because it's very sports driven and
you're not doing sports
you know what this needs a tiger and a
wolf
you're right well there's your tiger
right there
welcome back to the anthony can we get
the tiger off the [ __ ] screen please
thank you
hey dude you can't oh tiger i want my
whole video to look like a [ __ ]
puerto rican seat cover that you buy at
a
car wash first off i think you could you
could say taiga
taiga you can't use you can't use with
with a hard r
before we get started i want you to
watch the entire video if you liked the
video press the like button at the end
press the subscribe button at the end
and press the notifications button at
the end
okay today we're going to be talking
about how can we
only have a grill on the back of your
front teeth i was thinking
the same thing what is this a new look
that i don't know about
he has a grill in the absolute last
place you'd want to have a group yeah
like front top and then if you can
afford it front bottom
but he's just doing back bottom maybe
it's just bridge work
maybe last week
a lot of guys didn't you know what it
looks like you know like when you're
[ __ ] around as a kid and you use like
a gum wrapper to make a grill
exactly yeah but a lot of guys did know
so we're having this debate in the
manosphere
it's mike what part of the manosphere
are you in
people really need this
the people people waste so much
energy on so much lore that's not real
like this is all just
goofy made up gobbledygook it's nonsense
it's it's the manosphere this man has a
thing hanging on his wall that says
sigma
yeah because he's a sigma imagine like
creating a made-up hierarchy in your
head of how males are
and then also assigning yourself one of
the lower ranks
but like wearing that proudly
this is why women like it more you're
really gonna i think are you writing
this down
no could somebody write this down for me
please
and you know why royce because i don't
care
and because not caring will get you a
lot further in life with any of these
women and anything mr [ __ ]
25 of a girl over here is going to tell
you also hey youtubers
can you please stop getting the same
circular iphone camera thing
because you can always see it in their
eyes that they have that little ring the
ring i hate that you know it's funny i
considered buying one
but you're right that's the only reason
i didn't buy it is because you can see
it you can always see it yeah
about alphas and sigmas so today
we're going to go ahead and break down
the alphas and signals thank god now
to most of you guys your definition
of a alpha are you yelling at me is a
guy who has money
who has women and who is good looking
well yeah you have a lot of money you
sold all those albums
back in the day with ashanti and murder
inc
it's not your rule man i know are you
sure no no no
i thought he was in jail for firefest no
it's ciao rose it's not general i don't
think so
you know what i never say 100 i'm pretty
sure though
that's what you've been taught uh alpha
male is
all right what we're gonna do is we're
gonna break down those little
characteristics
all right can beta males have money yes
majority of the successful men in the
world
what makes this guy qualified to speak
on any of these things
he has a youtube channel oh fair enough
our beta metals
you have to understand no matter if your
alpha
no matter if your sigma your beta omega
delta zelta whatever's great you should
probably take your weed grinder out of
the
frame because it's really distracting me
now
all of these stupid [ __ ] terms
all of these dumb things that people are
doing now they're so
[ __ ] annoying just be a person be a
human being stop
categorizing yourself well the problem
is is these people are taking advantage
of autistic people who don't know how to
be a human being
and who look at everything through the
lens of like
like autistic spurgs love
this kind of stuff to speculate about
they love hierarchies
they love learning like it's like a
magic the gathering thing they love
learning the decks of cards they love
learning
the categories they love learning you
know what i mean it's like when you play
an rpg
they love learning all the different uh
specialties and classes you can build
right that's what it is they're upset
we've become that culture so
these guys have figured out a way to
clean up and make tons of money by
indulging these these spurgs but nothing
nothing that they're teaching is good
for you
mindsets are um midtown
red pill blue pill it's all mindsets
when you're mind changes i gotta read
some of the comments uh comments are
turned off
[Music]
it doesn't show a sub count either he's
real secretive about this
h so does the type of guy that you are
all right it's all about how confident
you are to society
when it comes to these different
mindsets but when it comes to the
definition of them and what you've been
taught
every man can have money and still be
weak
every man can have women and still be
weak you think this guy you think this
guy
like has like an older brother just
picks on him all the time
he has to and he's like yo auntie oh my
yo it's my little brother tony man yo
tony come here tell me
about your youtube channel bro yeah tell
them about your youtube channel yo will
you be talking about getting all that
[ __ ]
yo tony come here man yo t come here man
tell me
tell my boys about all that [ __ ] you be
getting what's that [ __ ] you was saying
alpha beta gamma delta well i don't know
man
that's got military codes and [ __ ] all
kind of [ __ ]
i don't know what the [ __ ] he'd be
saying half the time yo tony come here
tell us about your girlfriends
give me a little bro why you always
gotta be [ __ ] with me
dude when it comes to the beta male the
alpha
conquers the beta male and uses the beta
middle to get ahead
you know man i used to change these
little diapers you know we almost
you know we almost had them aborted
right because yeah because like we have
honestly we thought he was
right and they were like we dead ass bro
my grandma thought he was
bro but then like we had had him you
know i'm saying you can't have an
abortion on a baby that already you know
i'm saying be living and [ __ ]
so we like put he definitely like you
know i'm saying [ __ ] or some [ __ ] i
don't know
yo tony come here tell about your
youtube channel
you get one of the plaques yet you get
one of them little plaques
like pewdiepie whatever tariq nasheed
all right now we're getting to the
concepts you can be broke
and be a alpha male see your chads and
tyrones
are alpha males they may not even be
doing better than a beta male
but being that they have a dominant
mindset
this is what women are attracted to
they're not attracted to their money
they're not attracted to their looks
they're attractive well you're wrong
all these things are wrong women are
absolutely
attracted to money all right so let's
stop [ __ ]
i'm not gonna categorize stuff we just
live in a world where women are gonna
rather be with a guy that can [ __ ]
protect them
i mean that's just the way it is women
like to [ __ ] be on yachts
and tell their friends that they were
just having [ __ ] caviar yeah so of
course they are
that's [ __ ] not true look i'm not
saying a woman's not gonna [ __ ] a scrub
of course a woman will [ __ ] a scrub
but they absolutely are attracted to
money because it's not just the money it
also means you got your [ __ ] together
and then they also like these guys also
have this mentality like women
women like guys that are all muscular
and guys that are
you know uh that go bow hunting and [ __ ]
because women want to feel like they're
protected and you're like no this is a
modern world we live in women feel
protected if you have a lot of money
yeah women aren't going to like women
are not ever going to be walking down
the street and suddenly be surrounded by
saber-toothed tigers like
they want you to pay off their college
debt you know what i mean like it's
we live in a different world now having
money is far
superior to being a bow hunting alpha
male it's just
you have money it's like yeah i'll pay
off your stupid
credit card debt whatever yay thank you
lenny that's protection of them
protection of them is
oh [ __ ] okay i [ __ ] don't have to
declare bankruptcy because you paid off
my debt
locked it to their dominant mindset
because it's so it shows
hey tony when you gonna finish your
grill little what's up when you gonna
get that done
son yo tony been working on his grill
for like four years he ain't making no
youtube money though
he says something but they demonetize
him because he talked too much like a
white boy
is that true tony come here what's that
they said you was you you said uh they
said he was some kind of
what they say tony they said you were
like alt-right or some [ __ ]
yeah they said this little [ __ ]
using neon something
when you come when you're dealing with a
alpha a alpha is a person that's
constantly
aiming to conquer and does not allow
anyone to conquer him
alphas don't make [ __ ] youtube videos
about it
right yeah meanwhile his older brother
is the kind of guy that uh
that probably has some chick taking care
of him paying all his bills
and he sleeps on a mattress on the floor
yeah
you're right she says no money no
nothing and he's got like
four [ __ ] yelling at him three baby
mamas he's behind on child support and
this guy's
this guy's got a youtube channel where
he's like guys i'm telling you this
is how you get girls
or her but inside of that trait you have
sigma males
sigma males are the alpha males
that don't want to conquer they want to
be on their own
some alpha males thrive off the concord
ship
but then you have strong individuals
which are sigma mills
sigma males gain their power by the way
this is this isn't yet another cope
right
so sigma males which is what they say
like us or sigma males right
right we're alpha males and trust me bro
if we wanted to if we wanted to we would
dominate these other alphas
we would [ __ ] lord over them but we
don't want to be we don't feel like it
we don't have that desire bro it's not
about that for us
is that what you're telling me dude are
you that guy right now are you doing the
thing that
like it's like the guy that um the guy
that never works on like
you know making his lot better in life
like a dude that works the same job
forever
never applies for a promotion never
takes a couple of like extra classes at
night to try to
try to move up like most people should
always be trying to move up right
there are guys in life that just they
show up they punch a clock they're gonna
die punching the same clock they're
never gonna move up in life
and then they get drunk at bars and they
go ah you know these rich [ __ ]
yeah i would never sell my soul for all
that money nah man
and you're like you you're not you it's
it's all a cop everybody has these copes
for why they aren't where they are in
life
and that's that's an example of just
we're the sigmas we
we could we could stomp the [ __ ] out of
these alphas if we wanted to but
you know alphas are gross because they
have that desire we don't have that does
it stop making excuses
you're just a [ __ ] loser who uh
pri i'm going to guess i just want to
live in my fantasy world where he has a
way cooler older brother
and that's right his whole life is him
just
chasing his older brother's coolness he
just wants to be at school with his
brother and his brother has no job
his brother sits around all day with his
friends and just drinks on a stoop
somewhere
i'm a wolf pack of one this guy works 50
hours a week probably at some [ __ ] job
and his brother has no job and he always
has [ __ ] coming and going
and he probably sells really shitty weed
you know what i mean he's like
oh sigma's though we're not like the
alphas
such a [ __ ] nerd could you imagine
like
being like like studying this like i've
been trying to study
um how to read charts and get better at
investing because that
i can explain to you why i'm investing
so much time in that you go
why is he spending so much time lately
like writing in his notebook and looking
at charts
i'm trying to learn the rhythms of the
market and learn how to make money like
at least there's a reason for that these
guys are just learning all this lore
that
it's not real this is the same way as
this is the
the same thing as like when you go on
wikipedia
and you start learning like all of the
elder scrolls lore
because you're bored at work right like
it's that kind of thing
it's like you're okay you're just
passing the time at work so you're
reading about the the high
septum and the you know all that [ __ ]
and the graybeards but like it's because
you're bored at work
but these guys are like they really are
reading it as if it's a real thing like
they're learning a real thing well
it's not even that because even the
wikipedia for skyrim
or for or for elder scrolls it's based
on something it's based on something in
a game
these these pickup artists and these
sigma beta things it's not even based on
something that's observable
like it's not something that there isn't
a char there isn't an actual
wikipedia on what an alpha male is you
know or what a sigma is
oh i'm sorry yeah you're right there is
no wikipedia uh i believe there is an
infogalactic for it
no one uses that mic